la asamblea general de la onu condena la
invasión rusa y ucrania así lo ratifica
una resolución aprobada en una sesión
extraordinaria de emergencia que deplora
la agresión a ucrania y demanda la
retirada inmediata de las tropas de
moscú
cada voto a favor de la resolución y
cada firma de los países que votaron a
favor es una confirmación histórica de
la carta de la onu
es muy fácil señoras y señores firmar la
carta en tiempos de paz es el deber
firmar reconfirmar e implementar la
carta en tiempos de guerra la mente
chata de tango una clara mayoría
141 de los 193 miembros de la onu votó a
favor de la condena mientras que 5
países entre ellos rusia y belarús
votaron en contra y 35 decidieron
abstenerse entre ellos bolivia cuba el
salvador y nicaragua algunos de los que
se abstuvieron como china abocan por
abandonar la mentalidad de la guerra
fría esta es la undécima vez que el
organismo celebra una sesión
extraordinaria en su historia la última
vez fue en 1982 tras la invasión de los
altos de golán y en esta ocasión se
convocó tras el veto de rusia a una
resolución similar en el consejo de
seguridad de la onu del que es miembro
permanente
en el texto no se menciona nada sobre él
y legal a kiev en febrero del 2014
cuando con la connivencia de alemania
francia polonia el apoyo de eeuu cerró
cual presidente legítimamente elegido
del país y es que aunque las
resoluciones de la asamblea general de
la onu no son vinculantes tienen un gran
peso político y esta decisión aísla aún
más a rusia diplomáticamente ya
duramente golpeada tras las sanciones
económicas de occidente por su agresión
a ucrania